[inaudible]
for someone like me who's written a book
advocating what openly is an idea,
what sticks sounding version of foreign
policy.
It's a very hard time.
Uh,
I think for a bunch of different
reasons.
One is that eight years of the Bush
administration has not only exhausted
the larger world with this visionary
sweeping language and behavior and
foreign policy,
but the American people as well.
And so I think that there is a deep mood
of retrenchment,
uh,
in this country that is a wish,
not so much for different foreign policy
though there is that,
but also for less,
no grand adventures,
no grandiose language,
no talking about the universal
projection of American ideals.
Then you add to that the economic
crisis,
which not only means that foreign policy
is less salient than people would have
thought it would be,
would have been a couple months ago,
but also there's less money to spend on
things that otherwise you might
profitably spend money on.
It is true and it is a rebuke to the
great ambitions of bushes,
freedom agenda,
that in fact,
in recent years,
the growth of freedom has been either
nail or or negative.
When you measure it this way.
At the same time,
I would be cautious about saying there
is this concerted negative trend that
is,
we're talking about a relatively small
number of countries and it's a,
it's an index that shifts up and down.
You can certainly say there was no sign
of that democracy is growing in the
world,
but I don't think,
I think that would exaggerate the
ability of the United States to alter
things that are quite profound and
deeply rooted in their locality.
To think that just because George Bush
screwed up,
therefore the freedom is actually
heading into a nosedive.
[inaudible].